fire
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby you ever done this before
Brett yeah yeah this is a casual it's a
cashmere sweater it looks itchy yeah not
itchy are we rolling yeah we're rolling
yeah Brett Brett from New York Brent
Brent from New York yeah yeah Brent he
goes Brett you're from New York I know
Brent I know New Yorker I call him Brent
from New York but he's really Brett
Forte from Calgary Canada from kagari
now uh I was in Edmonton as you know and
it was 30 below yeah uh so that's all
you guys do you know you spend eight
months with no sun
yeah and on the news on the way here a
little bit of rain caused sinkholes
roofs
understatement we gotta [__] we're
still [__] tsunami here no the you were
when you get look at the Canadian
looking where'd you get in hey when did
you get in though um last week 37
million people [__] you did not okay how
bad was it last week though how about
okay you weren't here talking to a
Canadian look they so people in whatever
what's the neighborhood right now where
they're trapped oh we haven't been out
in two days on the news they're doing
phoners from people trapped in their
[__] eight car garages North
Hollywood you can't get out okay they
just did a two-year [__] pandemic and
now they're complaining about a weekend
in Calabasas yeah [__] you no it's not
Calabasas definitely not that whatever
it was it has to be North Hollywood no
it was something potholes fancy tabass
has a bubble whenever the weather gets
bad to school we're good this the street
the snow plow hasn't come yet and it's
like we don't even in Canada we don't
have snow plows you know what we have we
have men with trucks who put a shovel on
their front grill yeah a guy with an
F-150 takes care of it that's not an
exaggeration men well yeah here we go
now Canadians are men they're oil guys
what do you mean hold on hold on Calgary
and Edmonton I have a dictator no no but
Calgary and Edmonton are not with Mr
Trudeau Trudeau right yeah I mean you
get correct Calgary piece of [__]
totally yeah okay all right now you're
back in now you're back in I can dive
into it but Calgary Calgary and and
you'll correct me if I'm well they're
out there in the oil field yeah you got
bears and oil bro yeah right so the on
the way into Fort McMurray excuse me
Fort McMurray yeah uh there is a sign
that says please Don't Feed the Bears oh
that's the sign going into Fort McMurray
like they're [__] geese yeah yeah and
they're everywhere I said to the guy on
the oil I go how often do you see a bear
he goes weekly and then I said he goes
my camp
we got wolves that would sit just on the
edge of the camp looking while they're
working 12 Timberwolves just sitting
there looking at you like that so then
they went and got a [__] giant one of
those giant uh Anatolian Sheepdogs that
keeps Wolves Away then they had to get
two because that's how you keep the
Bears the Grizzlies and the [__] wool
they're scared of those sheep they're
not afraid of the Wolves they're not
going to kill you but they just come
into the camp and they're there you go
that's what you that's a badass dog oh a
sheep dog yeah I think I'm talking about
like a straight up I'm like well they're
just gonna eat that okay
I know that's that dog right there
and that dog was dog was to fight they'd
have it on a leash and try to fight the
whole [__] pack
but the grizzly bear nice girl that's
stupid
enough smoke and dog barks what's a
timber wolf size Giant and the ones in
Yellowstone are stupid the big boys well
the ones in Canada are the real deal
well in Canada I'm going to tell you
something
okay not that big uh 70 to 110 yeah why
don't you go ahead and bring up
do me a favor bring up the Wolves the
Timberwolf is what you're looking for
the huge Timberwolves in Yellowstone
there's not a single podcast in Canada
with two guys on the Google like this
this is incredible really yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh you guys just bro signs it yeah
yeah we search it up on Earth that's all
we used to do yeah we hold it up to the
camera
bring some pictures up here now of the
kind of wolves that we're talking about
Yellowstone you killed that wolf she's
hanging out with that wolf he looks
friendly no you gotta they're the when
they hunted them you'll see the Wolves
they're [__] giantic
oh yeah like don't worry about a wolf
man no they're not gonna [__] with you
you're not worried about a wolf oh look
at that stupid thing yeah not a dog yeah
dude out here we got Mountain lines
daddy you got friendly squirrels I just
showed Brandon this one dude it hopped
up on my shoulder dude Wild Squirrel
he's hanging out with this fight there
you go hey it's a big wolf
yeah but that sheepdog takes it yeah
that sheepdog's not hearing it he's
hanging out with this straight up
squirrel
while I go dude this isn't Canada don't
feed the [__] Street well you know
yeah yeah he came at you no he's hanging
out with him wow bit me
but watch it jumped on him hit me this
is this morning
are you kidding me what the [__] no
that's a gay squirrel where you at hold
on hold on uh yeah come on
SO for you guys who are listening is it
on Instagram no but I'll send it if
you're listening a squirrel send it to
chance just air drop it yeah but a
squirrel jumped on with people who are
listening a squirrel jumped on Brett
Brent from New York from New York yeah
West Hollywood but what's crazy what's
crazy about that that video is that no
there's you might have holy ghost power
something's going on with you that's
small animals if rats jump on you you're
probably evil but if squirrels land on
you you you I feel like you're so I got
a history a magic when I say that at a
hotel in North Hollywood pigeons came
into my room what I fed them I got video
of this too I'll airdrop to this guy
hold on I buy pigeons and that was the
first sty I ever got in my life okay A
little dirty yeah as you know second
style I got no word of lie when I shook
Joey Diaz's hand at The Comedy Store and
I rubbed my eye
and this will be style number three
evidently well so
um you're prone to say you're prone to
size but
a question it the chance you could be
the Messiah do you ever feel anything
like that it's been talked about on
Reddit but there's no confidence there's
a lot of chat around the water cooler a
little bit Yeah well what's what's the
the dog guy's name uh excuse me the
Bounty Hunter no you're like sorry the
Bounty Hunter
more than Caesar because
rest in peace to those that's big tips
pigeons and squirrels are drawn to you
I'm rodent myself look at me okay I
don't know about that you have broad
shoulders and you can hoop hey do you
know his backstory you know so his dad
uh bodybuilder would make turned his
room into a gym he had sleep on the
couch so his dad's like I need to work
out uh I didn't have a room I didn't
have a room uh I slept in the living
room which was converted into a
gymnasium okay I slept next to a weight
bench and a lap pull-down machine and I
used an Ikea chair to hold up the three
corners of my roof which was a sheet and
I slept on two sleeping bags till I was
17 and had a great time with my Dad
staying up late this is amazing hold on
your dad was a professional bodybuilder
no absolutely no no just a guy who
wanted to get big yeah just spinning all
my mom's hard-earned money getting 62
inch shoulders so finally I'm talking to
some guys that understand these
measurements 62 inch shoulders he's
natural he's five nine and a half never
took Sarah never took steroids uh
actually if this was the court of law
I'd have to say he did one cycle and he
got two uh aggravated and he had to come
off him right away so he was at least
sharp enough to know to get off him yeah
but yeah 20 inch arms he's 60 years old
right now and he's got 20 inch arms 62
inch shoulders the guy picture of this
guy yeah and then what did your mama do
uh she was an exotic dancer in the 80s
hold on this is but hey fans underground
stay relaxed okay
Ryan's Rock
and you're gonna like this he wasn't
just any ordinary dancer she was Miss
stag Exotica Canada five years in a row
maybe five
dude and then I ruined her body and I
put an end to the dynasty but yes she
was I gotta pull up some well we gotta
see how crazy you'll see chinsey's
MacBook if you want to airdrop it that
is insane not crazy yes yeah hey what
hey look I'm educating on my buddy here
nope what you're a little swollen in the
Facey Pacey oh what's going on I had
carbs last night a little um some booze
no it's okay because I did no not at
night no no no carbs do that drivers do
this yeah you get yeah you get well I've
been on Carnivore then oh you retained
some water you get a lot of pizza no
what'd you do uh carbs a lot of salt
it's Mediterranean okay
so you're a little congested in the old
facial area how it goes so are you you
know well but this is you've been very
very tight in the face and today you
look like a chipmunk that's how it goes
who's eating acorns storing acorns right
there it goes okay I'm gonna jump on
Brett's back now because that's what
rodents do yeah so wait this is so
interesting so squirrels are drawn to
you they caught the stranger squirrels
that are not tame climb on your back I
just saw it with my own eyes yeah that's
right your dad bodybuilder but not a
professional but took your entire house
over so you had to sleep the guy does a
gym membership nah he did he found other
ways to maximize you know his body for
example like he um before workout soaks
his arms in like scalding hot water in
the bathtub to open up the capillaries
and the veins and then you say
capillaries capillaries you're Canadian
we're an American now so capitalists
keep going keep going oh God oh God did
you say baboon as well or do baboon
how would I say it yeah ass red like a
baboon baboon yeah I would say I knew it
[__] knew it yeah how do you say
vitamins you say vitamins are vitamins
no vitamins okay yeah yeah yeah my dad
says NASA really bothers me he says
and also for the last like I don't know
only up until two years ago did I find
out how to say the word oregano properly
I've been saying Oregon
or common sounding like Sebastian
Maniscalco when I ordered I go I'll take
oregano I say oregano oregano and it's
straight up yeah it's good uh I go to
like Subway and they go big brother what
kind of bread do you want hey that's a
good Canadian accent well no that's
Filipino and um they uh and I go yeah
I'll take Parmesan oregano that's pretty
legit these people dude I gotta find
this [__] photo my dad there's no
internet in this [__] bomb shelter
we're in right now we gotta uh we
probably should connect you to the Wi-Fi
that would help that would have been
nice the code is so long it's right
there I want to see everyone with the
check mark you want to see my mom and I
want to see your dad yeah see what
brought you into this [__] world yeah
yeah all right let's take a quick break
can we take a little break because I'll
be in Brea this Friday you will be with
our guests Brett Forte okay you know as
Brett from Brent from New York from New
York but Forte is with me in Brea two
shows only because Saturday of the fight
companion with jelly roll Rampage and
Will Compton for UFC 285 7 P.M live on
thick boy YouTube but come see me and
Brett and Brett two shows only this
Friday then an Oklahoma City March 9th
through the 11th then Tacoma Washington
March 23rd through the 25th look I'll be
in I'll be in Zanies this weekend kids
but uh Saturday's already sold out so
get your tickets I'm doing a crowdcast
Friday 12 30 Pacific time
uh with Stephen Cutler who's an expert
in flow Peak Performance and uh
performance aging you say crowd now
we're doing a live show yeah we're doing
a q a and everything so you guys can uh
call in so I'll put the link up at
briancount.com Sunny Hall March 11th
I'll see you there one show only all
right let's move on uh you just said to
me we're about to do a read for athletic
greens and you lose you just said you go
I wish I I love that stuff I wish they'd
I got to get more yeah I was taking it
every day for a year so it's actually
delicious but it also makes you feel
really really good it's got pretty much
everything you want gut health sustained
energy support everything it's got all
the things that you need in one scoop um
and some of the most high performing
people I know like myself take it but it
really is it tastes really good and it
really is effective it's it's a it's an
amazing thing to do to make sure you get
a completely well-rounded nutrition
nutritional doubt dude right no doubt
all right look I
key daily nutrients long-term gut health
which is everything uh costs less than a
three dollars a day that's not bad for
good health yeah if you want to be
healthy freaking drink ag1 look if a
comprehensive solution is what you need
for your supplement routine athletic
greens is giving you a free one-year
supply of vitamin D and five free travel
packs with your first purchase go
athletic greens.com spider that's the
athletic greens.com fighter check it out
dude I can't focus man oh my God
I can't remember anything oh my God it's
all cloudy yeah I'm all cloudy you need
the best nootropic on the planet what
Alpha Brain from our friends at honor
yeah but listen long terms we've been
taking Alpha Brain but you know those
Alpha Brain instincts how about black
people talk about black ladies black
labels for the people like me yeah I
always take it overboard and on it goes
we know this you're a big boy you got a
big head the big head big brain small
brain on back I don't know Alpha Brain
Black okay for brain black when you do
that super boring podcast you should be
on Alpha Brain Black right and because
no one's tuning in uh Alpha Brain Focus
shot are also good as well and you
should take that when you do that thing
no one's gonna watch uh so it's Alpha
Brain Focus shot and he saved go to
audit.com fighter you save is it flash
fighter yeah
oh my bad it's on it.com
get some krill oil yeah dude the CTS at
the gates and the Alpha Brain is just
keep them at Bay thank God they got it
all they got creatine they got workout
gear they got streaming Fitness
that is that's actually a crazy good
workout it really is a workout yep steel
Club maces steel maces quad maces on it
sandbags yoga mats we got it all but if
you want that Alpha Brain Black that
highly concentrated nootropic they've
sold over a million bottles of the world
reason because it works I like the
instant shot the focus shot go to
audit.com
f-a-t-k all right and you get temps off
the entire site Alpha I'm tired and in
the entire site guys audit.com f-a-t-k
10 off so he yeah so you'd walk down the
hallway with dripping arms down to the
gym and he'd he get the workout's not
over until the measurement is received
by the way putting his arms installing
hot water is the craziest [__] I've
heard all these stories that's why I
want you to it's insane and the point
was to be in his own house and to be
made no money to dilate no money doing
it making no money just for the [__] of
it wow this guy's great that's called
that that's called a a strange hobby
right yeah by the way my great dad you
won't have a room because my arms come
first
but you get along with them yep he's a
good dad
he's fantastic I got another photo here
of [__] uh animals because I'm
digging by digging through here
and you know there's me with a bunch of
I think these are called uh lemurs yeah
this might be lemurs I think they might
be lemurs are those like raccoonish kind
of those lemurs the fighter in the kid
iMac is that their drop no no the
chinsuyi MacBook okay
yeah my whole thing has been okay is he
gonna be a little rusty is he even ready
to go I I got word from my my boy who's
in at the camp yeah been around John his
entire career okay
he said okay
he's never seen him like the the best
cardio he's ever seen
five rounds easy easy work he's never
seen him like this ever in his life okay
ever I'm already nervous yep it should
be really and he's looking good
good on ungodly light they said he goes
I'm you've never seen this version of
John in your life ago we're talking
about John Gus Finn like UFC 165. he
goes oh bubba this dude is on a
different because he's training now but
it is for three years and he's also been
ready to go since last year but the UFC
couldn't get him a fight so he's been
doing camps because I was like I'm a
little worried with a long laugh because
Tony dude he's been ready to go there's
not gonna be any ring wrath none of that
[__] he's just ready to go so you've
never seen him the best version he's
ever seen oh my Lord because he's the
best fighter I've ever seen right now
currently the best I've ever seen him
which is scary scary as [__] and when
what two he'll walk in at 260 2 45 uh
right around 250 I bet well you when you
knew him when he was off campus he would
walk at 2 30. oh he's 240. he was that
big yeah I'll show you 245.
27 only available in Calgary Alberta a
special uh edition only for Canada
this is a picture of his dad with very
skinny and probably
nine-year-old Brett that's Brent from
New York yup yes Brett and your dad has
cut off jean shorts and they are just
below his balls in fact if he would have
put his foot up on a tree stump nut his
nuts would pop right out of those shorts
true or false that is so let me tell you
a moment I saw them come out huh
um
so this guy here uh neighbors are
enemies that's how I grew up when I grew
up when you grow up in an apartment
building uh there's no friends there's
no they're not neighbors they're enemies
and they made a bunch of noise all the
time my dad was a light sleeper and uh
one day the upstairs neighbor we're
sitting on our balcony just hanging out
both this age and uh a wet weiner comes
flying down in our balcony just Huck
down onto ours weiner is a Canadian for
a hot dog yeah sorry buddy because in
West Hollywood a wet wiener is not fun
all right we're not in West Hollywood
dude he is okay fine I just want him to
know like get a website you want a wet
wiener it's not gonna be a hot dog
hot [__] all right good yeah and I'm
Canadian so you can come in me I didn't
know that yeah cheers
this kind of Canadian guy and call him a
hot piece of [__] but you identify Gap
I'll tell you later oh yeah
huge bomb so you're so back to your pops
in the wetsuits the hot dog comes flying
down uh and then we're like what the
[__] and then another one come two now
that's too much one yeah two accidents
happen yeah hey so my dad Funk pops up
right away and he comes around he goes
hey
barks up he goes I see you next time you
do that you're done I think that's all
he said next time I see that you're done
yeah
sure enough [__] I think a day later
they meet each other in the hallway and
I'm playing video games and I feel the
building shake and I go what the [__]
was that and I ran out into the hallway
and my dad's got to the guy swallowed up
in the uh hallway of the apartment on
top of them like like GSP sprawl sort of
thing like just dominance in those
shorts
let him finish yes in those shorts every
hallway in the door is open Mothers and
children are watching the [__]
commotion my dad like a lion with his
like nuts stacked in the [__] air
okay on top of this guy yeah and yeah he
goes to move like over like and just
what you're talking about the nuts fall
right out yeah that's good that's what
happens oh yeah so those are those are
the risks you take because you can't be
sprawling on somebody in those shorts
you can't do it much in those shorts
besides walk a straight line and benches
your balls are gonna find their way to
Freedom yeah your dad is there you know
the mothers they didn't even cover the
children's eyes they're like you need to
see this yeah this could all be yours
one day yeah this is how kind of I
learned to be a man you know watching
and where did they have meats and where
did dad meet Mom at the the place of
business no uh through just a friend of
a friend and get this man my mom I guess
was pretty like uh forward when they met
uh they were just kind of introduced to
each other some can I see Mom because if
that was that that picture by the way
everybody should know was as blurry as
any UFO picture I've ever seen that
could have been big would you mind
having a picture that that's somewhat
pixelated it looks like mankind with a
small Indian boy that's actually 100
it's He-Man that's actually 100 sure and
my mom as it would be pole cat right but
um
I wasn't gonna say here he's a
barrel-chested kid he's a big boy yeah
that's a big guy mom was forward you you
get you get your mother's bone structure
you you're more of an ectomorph not a
mesomorph like him that's right that's
right Daddy's Dead uh it'll take a while
okay I need the the Wi-Fi well you look
for it you know I was watched last night
is that uh murder on uh Netflix oh dude
no I've been following the case they've
been following the case yeah I don't
realize how terrible that family is and
how powerful in South Carolina awful
people well he goes back the kid who was
shot was already I think gonna be in
trouble for killing a girl in a boating
accident or being sued so so what
happened was with you they had like a
close group of friends he was like
raging alcoholic like drinking non-stop
was notoriously known for hitting his
girlfriend right so they all get
together they're going some oyster
barbecue which is I guess out in South
Carolina they do oyster barbecues so
they go there they all get on the boat
to to go there they get hammered they
said he's drinking six like Miller
lights into a funnel he's hammered like
hey you can't drive he's like my [__]
boat starts yell at them his his
girlfriend at the time is like hey you
shouldn't be driving someone should be
driving the boat he slaps in front of
all the friends
and then this is what kind of kid you're
dealing with that and I don't trust
redheads in general so the whole family
off the bat I don't like yeah hate
redheads okay my kids are ginger but
keep going those are not my kid which
one the new one my newest one is new
though I'm still feeling out I think
he's going to go yeah he'll go he's a
little summer strawberry and he's gonna
say he's got brown eyes yeah brown eyes
red hair yeah but it's like okay we'll
figure it out let's not judge him yet
he's still young yes keep going so um so
they get on the boat he slaps girl and
then you go tell he goes you know what's
the worst part about you your dad
doesn't make enough money to support
your family so that's what kind of kid
you're dealing with oh he seems like so
he's hammered and he and she says she
yells at him he floors the boat it runs
into a bridge everyone gets launched out
of the boat he's driving the girl who is
his best friend's girlfriend gets hit
flying out of the boat hits one of the
the pylons around the bridges pylons uh
head trauma Jesus Christ his mom uh goes
down goes down the water she dies
they're all at the hospital the murder
of family comes the dad and the grandpa
the Grandma's the most powerful one and
then the dad right we're all attorneys
yeah
they run the whole entire town yeah
they start
to get into the family before the cops
do going well and they go they blame it
they go well that kid was driving right
and like no no your son was driving like
no no no he wasn't right so they're
trying to like Forge a story so the
sun's okay
they find the body whatever like 15 days
later she's dead
year three years ago by nothing no one's
heard of anything and the family's like
what the [__] our daughter's dead
someone needs to pay this price finally
they look up the call records the dad
and the grandpa were all calling the
cops the police station investigating
the lead investigator and telling them
what to do
they're all behind it just so so the
kids are on trial for murder three years
ago by pandemic hits three years by
nothing happens as a kid and then the
kid ends up getting shot to death and
the mom now here's where it gets
interesting two Shooters yep there's two
Shooters mom was shot uh with the AR-15
some was shot multiple times with a
shotgun with two Shooters yeah so we
don't know if they're dead it was staged
now go back now go back prior to this
six years to all this happens
there's a kid at their local high school
the handsome kid gay though think he was
hooking up with older brother
well they don't want that on the family
name what do you think happens that kid
he got killed he got killed but they
found in the middle of the road the cops
investigator well hold on this kid was
beat way before this he didn't get hit
by a car and the way the body's
positions don't make sense they track it
back to the oldest son who's in the car
that night because his car broke down
the the Murdoch Brothers pulled over
killed him he said the worst people on
the planet is worst [__] the only
thing is maybe the dad killed it because
of financial stress maybe but the two
Shooters there's only one there's only
one tracks of cars that the only the
tracks of the car there's only one car
there's only one track a set of boots
that [__] guy killed his own son has
killed his [__] wife he used two guns
to make it look like that then he staged
his own assassination and wanted to
blame the cousin correct a dumb cousin
here's where it gets interesting is that
they again phone records the dad did not
call the cops first he made other calls
before I'm surprised how weird is that
well some people are so bad redheads
some people are so bad though I don't
know now hold on I don't know if we can
draw that correlation scientifically No
Case Closed not the commercials no we
have some good friends I mean and
Anderson Tina's a redhead he wouldn't do
that so we know some people no no you
can't just throw all gingers under the
under the bus here like that I'm just
saying I don't think it's the red hair I
think it's just that some people are so
bad you can't believe it yeah some
people are so bad the whole family but I
mean there are people who will kill
their own children and be like good I
get insurance money like there are
people like that oh it's terrible it's
incredible majority of those are red no
I don't know if that's true I'd have to
look like that Jen can we look that up
actually look it up
in the middle of this murder
story your mom popped up oh yeah your
mom's a Bonafide dime so uh that's her
as a sunshine girl on that that's a big
thing in our uh paper
it says you can count on Kim sunshine
girl 1988 she was an accountant at that
time
now where do you get your dark
complexion from your mom's not dark your
dad from that blurry pictures white I
know dude what's happening I don't look
you don't look like any of them so the
story is
okay
um are you Indian
First Nation look my dad obviously big
into muscle Books Okay
well that's where he'd get his
literature you know there was no
internet Fitness yeah he's a trainer and
I guess he found out through these books
that when a woman is pregnant it is
healthy for the baby if you take high
levels of niacin
uh you know what happens when you take
high levels of niacin flush you get
flushed you're looking at a permanent
flush I was the first designer baby oh
wow
um you're always blushing in other words
that's right
but your blood your blood must be rather
dark let's find out
that is strange yeah really interesting
yeah I don't know I think it works out
because uh I'm kind of like ethnically
ambiguous me too I'm the only dark one
in my family although I was the brown
kid growing up I was like bullied for
being the brown kid that's cool and you
know how I got away from this this is
[__] so we're talking like grade two
everyone's like hey you're the brown kid
blah blah like where are you from where
are you from and I just I go um
I don't uh I don't really know and
they're like what do you mean you don't
know and I was like look I was only told
that I was adopted and apparently the
ship I came on the crate I was in I
guess all that was written on it was
fiscus
f-i-s-k-i-s so they think that might be
my name I don't know that's all I'm told
is I came out of a crate with Fiska
stamped on it and the kids were just
like oh okay we'll move on they didn't
believe us no bullying after that oh man
one fake story
yeah it's a great boy yeah
like my buddy Nick said that he said he
I went to school with a lot of black
kids in the Bronx and so it got him so
ready to be a stand-up because you get
roasted you you went to All Blacks
that's all you do you just get it gross
everything everything everything yeah
uh I never had that no no no my sister's
kids don't have those my son uh I have
to go talk to the teachers because my
son did a little shoving
and uh I don't know how to T I don't
know how old is he well he's 11 but it's
like but what happened yeah what
happened yeah
I mean I think you take a photo or you
just start pushing I think the kid rang
the bell like I think the kid rang the
school bell really wasn't supposed to
okay and my someone a don't do that and
push them down
walked away kind of I don't you know I
have to find out what the circumstances
are but I have to go in and talk to them
and I'm not sure what I'm going to say
and how just get contrary so yeah I'd be
like why why am I you know punching is
one thing about getting shoved is
another thing right did you shove them
to the ground I think the kid went to
the ground good yeah I'm proud but he
won't ring the bell early little dumb
[__] there are those things yes
considerations I'd say should he be
ringing the bell sounds like my son's
doing a job you guys should have been
doing yeah I'm gonna I'm probably gonna
have to remain quiet and listen to what
happened oh I argue you guys should go
as Two Dads you should say you're both
fathers
day aggressive day dads gay dads yeah
and you're wearing the shorts his dad
wore yeah and my nuts just there yeah
I'm dressed like you oh yeah that's
right nice in that outfit we got similar
bodies we could do a so I could swap
that casual I'm a little more happy with
your about it you're young tall they're
both skinny though yeah yeah but but
when when I was a kid even when you're a
kid shoving my kid wouldn't get a call
unless there was like blood or like
straight up straight up
yeah this is a different time we're in
where where aggression is considered uh
was it a white kitty push I don't know
I'm not gonna know that's great
questions oh see I need contact
was an Asian kid I don't know guys I
don't think my kid is aware of color I
promise no he is 11. well that's
definitely when it starts popping no
guys I just want to is there a crayon he
avoid in the back yeah
what you heard me
Guys these are uncomfortable questions
for me right now
hmm one of my dad's proudest moments is
when he was picking me up from school
and he saw me take care of myself I put
a guy just grabbed his arm in his elbow
and put him to the ground and held him
there the dad's like hell yeah he can
defend him for himself yeah well I had
you need contacts in your situation
I'm going open-minded and then what does
Mom say I get along very well with uh
the principal I love her she's cool and
it's a good school and that's good for
my kid so depends how woke it is yeah
well your kids can be spent I think that
my my huge problem with anything which
they haven't done in my school but like
you got these schools that are teaching
kids when they're toddlers about gender
and about gender fluidity and stuff and
I'm violently opposed to that how about
that you also have places in California
where you're not allowed to disclose
that you know this kid now is having
gender dysphoria or whatever the [__]
you want to call it and identifying as
this and that and the other thing which
mostly is social contagion no I'm sorry
having actual gender for you is super
[__] rare super rare Jordan Peterson
over here social contagion yeah yeah
that's by the way exactly what I'm doing
yeah but I've looked into it it makes me
angry I've been alive
I'm 56. I've been uh we had one
transgender person when I was growing up
and they did a 60-minute special about
the person I'm not saying they weren't
others we had zero well I'm not saying
that that it doesn't exist as a
phenomenon it's very very very rare and
the idea that so let me give you an
example let me get your take on this so
the gasca our district attorney who uh
he who he basically suspended the lead
prosecutor in a case with a guy who
raped two women uh children children
okay and then said I identify as a woman
still got a beard and stuff they haven't
recorded on phone calls in the prison
saying hey I'm going to pretend I'm a
[__] quote unquote
so that I can get into the female prison
trading where his words yeah and then so
uh this is what this [__] scumbag
who's gaming the system said who's a
child rapist said okay why am I doing
this with a fake phone oh yeah it's a
prison phone yeah yeah so dumb dumb was
caught talking to his dad about this so
now they know that the prosecutor the
prosecutor mentions him by his real name
and refers to him as a guy which is all
of what he is he's all of that and he
got suspended because this [__]
psycho [__] found a loophole to
get into a woman's prison
now Tim Kennedy post this now the same
exact thing happened somewhere in Africa
two two gentlemen raped a girl and
murdered her you know what happened to
them they got Time Squad that's right
yes that would be that would be that's
called jealousy appropriate yeah that's
called appropriate and we we live in
California now where that's and
California's basically Canada they just
they just reversed this law but you
weren't even allowed as a therapist if a
kid said I feel like a man or I feel
like a woman and I'm a girl I'm the
opposite you weren't allowed to actually
say to them well let's talk about maybe
the fact that you're confused about
something else maybe you're autistic
maybe you have something maybe you watch
Little Mermaid conversion therapy so if
you're gay I can't get it that's
grooming AKA grooming it's it's it's not
good but they're it's grooming because
those kids are so young they're so
influential and they're the enemy and
they kept our kids in masks and out of
school when they killed none I'm they're
my enemy I don't want them as friends
and I don't want to meet them halfway
talk that [__] I hate him yeah I think
most people agree with you but yeah I
know you have a hot take right now I
mean most America is with you yeah I
know yeah but I'm old and white so
people are like
yeah typical yeah but watch you go on
your son's school you'll be seeing it
different too like this aggressions out
this is outrageous like was it a black
kid you know what I'm gonna do for that
black kid yeah I'm gonna adopt them
what do you know about Canadian politics
right now what do you hear Trudeau I
know Trudeau's the son of Castro I watch
a hot tape I watch your I watch your uh
parliamentary debates I love it
Canadian families yeah uh uh we we are
there for them we will always be there
for them and and and and my colleagues
on the other side of the aisle and then
they but the conservatives always
eviscerate him so what do you know about
the trucker Convoy up in Canada I think
it was no they're [__] freedom I
think they were all I think they were
all
out there protesting and exercising
their rights as Free People supposedly
and I know it did nothing and and and
they were branded massages they were
Nazis they were branded racist they were
branded all these things
um yeah come together so let me tell you
I thank you I was there oh you were on
the ground oh I gotta hear it so you
were in the yes oh wow
um not participating in it but covering
it yeah so to speak uh I do like stories
that matter a little bit of Rogue
journalism on my Instagram account right
so what the first blockade was uh the
Alberta border with uh United States it
was Coots it's called the Coots border
uh is like a two-hour drive from me so I
went down to see exactly what's going on
so they now that is just one land
Crossing of I think 130 between Canada
and the United States and they because
of that blocking and the one in Ottawa
two out of 130 they declared it a
national emergency so they invoked the
emergencies act which I guess is similar
to like martial law yeah here yep so cut
to horses stampeding through people
stomping on people tear gas riot shields
because some semi trucks were parked in
front of Parliament building AKA your
white house or something we call them
semi trucks but you keep going what did
I say Sammy doesn't matter I'll try to
interrupt one more and the cashmere is
coming up all right one more let me know
man all right keep going I apologize
that silicone ring you're wearing is
that so that you don't cut your opponent
is so frustrating
when I climb ropes when I do the [__] I
do a lot of secret stuff I can't have it
just never looked right can't have a
metal kitten it just never fits I know
it's the guy that keeps wearing a hat
you're like you don't wear the hat
matches my black shoes it's like a
rubber washer you'd put in like the sink
fine keep going dude keep going um damn
it
you know what I mean there's a 128 other
Crossings you can go by there's no need
to invoke the emergencies act right but
it was just kind of a stain on the
country so they did that now me
personally in Coots down there uh seeing
these fellas in their semi trucks okay
they uh were so well behaved to the
point where they didn't even have open
liquor they said we can't even give the
police any reason to take us down we are
here and we are trying to negotiate for
our rights and freedoms which means uh
[__] your vax pass for me to work as a
trucker uh
et cetera et cetera all these things
okay so I'm down there very well behaved
people to this day for them are still in
prison on charges Jesus for conspiracy
to kill an officer wow one of them still
phones my friend uh from prison 20
minutes a day and he's been in there
locked up for over a year and uh the
government straight up lied so I'm down
there they're all well behaved no open
liquor you go home on the news they said
uh yeah we got sideswiped RCMP officers
were sideswiped in a truck they were
attacked Jason Kennedy Kenny our uh
Premier at the time came on national
news and said this that these truckers
attacked our police officers that was a
straight up lie unbelievable to get the
public on board yes to block uh your
access to public access to even go down
there and see I had to sneak in I faked
a contract to say that I'm hired as a
comedian to go work at the pub to do a
show that still wasn't enough what they
had was a guy in a ski suit and a helmet
in ski standing in the middle of the
highway and the cops shot down the whole
highway and they said hey we got a
dangerous situation here we can't let
anyone through I'm like [__] you that's
a cop in a ski helmet that's one of your
boys I know what's going on here so I
should have covered yourself in squirrel
I found the back way a guy drove us uh
through this is on my Instagram I
documented it all in and they took us
down the back path and that's where I
got to meet these guys
tyranny bro yeah dude two doors a
straight up dictator and now they just
had the emergencies act inquiry which
means uh they get to look back at the
books and see was Justin Trudeau
justified in doing what he did and no
surprise uh yes he was yeah of course
um
but the story I'm telling is a little
different than that damn now he's been
canceled how many times well
I don't know if you would ask me because
he had a joke I'm bad great joke my
national television network CBC are you
yeah yeah what
he had a great joke it was about an
Indian guy right seek guy saved a woman
out of the river with his turban he
unraveled it he threw it in he saved her
this is a real story he's a [__] hero
this happened in Kamloops British
Columbia like five years ago
and my whole bid on it was like isn't
this guy a hero like he unraveled his
turban like a whip like a lasso like and
the paper says man saves drowning woman
this is the work of no man this is the
work of East Indiana Jones so I gave him
a nickname I championed the guy uh but
unfortunately I got hit with a smear job
and uh during seek Awareness Month
by the way it's pronounced sick if
you're truly in the know okay but we
seek so during sick awareness month on
the anniversary of the 85 genocide uh
they were looking for their clicks just
like I was looking for mine an activist
in the sea Community they took a piece
of my bit not the part where I'm saying
this guy's a hero and everyone clapping
they took the one part where I'm like
mimicking with the mic chord a turban
throwing it in like it was a great joke
that's not uh we were just talking off
her about doing the voice and how a lot
of people say oh you can't do the voice
and so your network banned you for that
because I had a special on CBC and it
was live for a week and as soon as I got
a thousand death threats I got a
thousand straight up death threats
knives guns sent to me all these images
because you know because I always use
Brett whenever I torcana or if he's down
here I always use them and even the
venues that I was gonna use in Canada
like oh with Brad we don't know I'm like
what the [__] you yeah still no no
you're fine now oh but this before it
was always happening I was like wait
what are you over the the Indiana Jones
get the [__] out of here yeah that's
such a bummer you had some bad eggs you
know people who are super sensitive in
the c community or whatever but they
only saw a clip of it I went to the
guadora and I met with 10 elders and I
sat in a circle and talked about the
joke and talked about what the
sensitivities are in their culture and
what I can get away with they're tough
people it was the toughest crowd I've
ever been a part of I tried a couple
jokes okay we're in the circle most of
them don't speak English
and they're telling me about their gurus
like they got tennis yeah on horses and
uh then they're telling me about the
Sikh farmer that is like uh feeding all
these people he's a real hero and they
showed me a picture and I was like okay
well first of all mine go my mind says
this guy looks like Guru number seven is
that offensive is that and they go yes
very I go holy [__] no look you can't
even make a you can't wait I think that
you walked in there the enemy and so
like like any enemy territory like they
so the Sikhs make up majority of the
Indian army they're a warrior class man
yeah well they they wear on bangle they
they never cut their hair they carry a
knife
traditionally there there are there are
warrior class but but um at the same
time I think that you were just a victim
of they just there was you were the bad
guy that that's ridiculous yeah but it
was fun it was very Like Larry David of
me to go to the Gurdwara and like sit
with them and lean into it and talk
about it yeah smart and uh because you
didn't do anything wrong and that's not
a and and the fact that you told the
joke that some people found offensive
after that TV and
pulled it right pulled out is is that's
the crime not that your joke uh offended
a certain group of people that got it
out of context that that the the fact
that they are so gutless they're so
gutless and they have no spine and
they're all little [__] yeah the old
man fired up dude
it's true but he also sold Indiana Jones
merch
lemonade out of lemons everybody
lemonade out of legs banned from CBC
okay is that a business credit I bet
then being on CBS sure when the MC goes
your headliner is banned from CBC people
look left and right and that says
something that's great but CBC what
would that was my best credit what would
that be in America like what kind of
news do you have a network that is
government funded here uh see an NPR to
an extent not really no we don't know
it's funded by Pfizer so similar okay so
it'd be similar to that and um but back
then if I could go back I wouldn't have
even apologized or anything I would have
leaned do you apologize well I uh Mark
Cuban's PR guy somehow wrote an apology
for me for you and I'm a huge fan of the
Dallas Mavericks and I was like if it's
good enough for Luca doncic it's good
enough for me post it yeah but now going
back I wouldn't have posted anything and
then I realized I don't know if you guys
like uh shells and stuff like that
there's a
formula if you if someone's mad at you
air that out and then the other side
will be angry at them and you you stand
to make more money yes
well you're also being honest you don't
have to be honest it showed me Schultz
yeah he did a Toronto venue Andrew
Schultz did a a Toronto venue and they
pulled out yes and then the venue across
the street that was like twice the size
said yeah we'll do it out of spite yeah
why did they pull out from Andrew they
didn't like some of his jokes content
yeah yeah and then this happened to us I
toured the danger cats uh Sam Walker and
Uncle hack and this is we do 200 to 400
seat venues across Canada right danger
cats danger cats yeah danger cats comedy
now we lock up the phones and everything
we make sure we protect ourselves but we
also
um it's a better experience for the
customers Logan does that now yeah
they're great all the big boys do Kevin
Hart has done that he's the first one
I've heard of doing it Chappelle does
that yeah and are you doing a Comedy
Works in Denver yes it I think every
Club should install I love it yeah but
they've all been hit with cancellations
and every time we've doubled down and
it's called the spite tour for a reason
we literally just added to the list good
Spike tour refuel yeah Runway it's good
it's good there's so many Canadians and
so many people who are so done with this
[__] you just made some money people
yeah I'm a real hardcore people the
majority of them are great you got the
biggest idiots who are those now has the
sea Community come back around are you
that's that's so in the rearview mirror
yeah yeah this will probably kick up
some of the Dust you know but uh
saw the joke itself it's like they
didn't see those what happens you have a
small group of people that are crazy you
you gotta you gotta back your boy that's
how human beings are they're like I got
it back you know I'm already a minority
I gotta back my boy but and it was
during seek Awareness Month keep in mind
it's during like they need it yeah you
know because dude I I was I was doing I
was at the comic strip and uh there are
just a bunch of Sikhs you know um over
there and it was after after 9 11 a lot
of Sikhs got targeted because they were
they were a turban they had their hair
you know and so they got a lot of they
got a lot of [__] but they have nothing
to do with Islam it's a very different
religion all that stuff and so I kind of
I know that I've known I grew up around
I lived in India I know enough about it
so I I uh all I did was I just looked
over and I go
oh we got the Sikh Mafia in the house
and they just [__] went wow you know
because any group that hasn't been
recognized yeah you know once you once
you honor them or you know a little bit
about their who they are they [__] go
nuts that's good at least you went to
the [__] Temple at least you went to
there yeah it was fun I learned more
about their culture now I know how to
pronounce it properly I know about the
kurpond the Gurdwara of the you know the
gurus there you go and then the latest
one to get upset at us was the first
Nations Channel I saw you had the
Instagram up the top right the one that
says fired yeah that video right here
I lose a commercial over this
me a refresher real quick I think you're
on the right track what happened here
this should cover it yeah so I do a uh
commercial for the Alberta Forest
industry they got me uh three day shoot
uh stunt doubles [__] wires cameras
25 person crew a lot went into this
point is on the very last day everyone
collapsed that's a shoot everyone that's
a that's a wrap well not so fast because
I got a call from the director on the
way home he goes hey man uh I just got a
very angry phone call from the agency
they say they found a video of you
online
okay here we go what is it they go did
you ever
mimic a kid with cerebral palsy in the
front row of one of your comedy shows I
know he's a comic right oh no
but you know like I write it down like
good idea right I don't know he goes all
right let me call him back let me smooth
this thing out this is the video they
found
roast battle he's participating he's a
comic he's in a row he's in the roast
battle he's on stage up there all the
time
I've seen this kid
you even need the
chairs
[Music]
all right so because of that clip that's
in the commercial completely oh my God
uh the entire video crew has to be
re-hired to shoot the whole thing again
any other paycheck you're welcome yeah
everyone gets paid sacrifice a goose for
the gander I've always said that wow I'm
that goose that goofy is also caught
from the radio ads they're so upset they
won't even let my voice represent their
company now that comes from a place of
pure spite
which oddly I respect okay now this is
going to break my mom's heart just she's
finding this at the same time you are
she was very excited to see her little
boy
on TV but that's no longer gonna happen
Mom I'm sorry
okay just skip my ad on YouTube yeah but
uh okay and I got this it's unfucking
believable all you were doing was
actually empowering that guy that was
great and you get [__] the the guys
Canadians have lost their minds this
this whole industry is crazy it's just
those that whoever is yeah
unbelievable
there's one more here here we'll cover
all the three cancellations in two ass
how many times has been canceled three
times here's the third just scroll down
a little bit it'll be on the left keep
going keep going and what did they say
then yeah that was it that was it yeah
that's right there uh left I think cell
phone car left
four left so
um some stand-up shows of mine have been
canceled this girl's great
excuse me the bangs of Justice
I'm sure you've seen some of the things
that have been said to me never make a
joke about people wearing masks again
some of the names I've been called
there it is
I can take it but you're doing God's
work affects my livelihood and the
people around me and you know venues and
managers being contacted it doesn't ever
stop in the showroom or in the DMS on
Instagram it always goes a step further
so now 30 calls have been made to venues
in BC okay the uh Prince George and
Smithers run
is over
because of this how many people in
Edmonton are willing to go and protest
or do something to get the show canceled
and it leads to the venues making
uh Facebook statuses like this we've had
several messages in comments of our
opinion comedy show on August 18 to 19.
regarding one of the colors
several messages
[Music]
that was quick
good job everyone how crazy she's having
her little celebration now we get to
have arms we get the last laugh because
what they've done for us is a face
because any event that allows your teeth
are straight
or just as guilty but luckily not all
should have your shins
create jokes just despite you just to
throw it in your [__] face and I like
that it's why the Blazer's on because we
just got upgraded to the salmar classic
theater yes yes it ain't a show
Spike show this is so good these people
now bretfordday.com it's a beautiful
thing but the only clown here in this
particular instance is you
deserve sir you have a nose piercing
you're the days I deserve boys
for those of you guys listening that the
woman was like she looked that's not to
be mean but those teeth like my friend
used to say you could throw an Apple at
her face and it would stick those are
the craziest teeth I've ever seen in my
life she was having a hard time you can
look at her eyes they're going in both
different directions one's going swirly
she's crazy and the other guy the other
guy shaves his eyebrows so you already
know you're dealing with crazy crazy
that guy shaves his eyebrows nothing
else to do with his facial hair you're
dealing with cuckoo birds and they just
what it's it's good for you it's water
off the duck's back baby it's great look
at this establishment I'm in right now
and they literally drove you to a bigger
venue after this so Justice Warriors
thank you for making the world more
Equitable so now I'm like
I'm like Garfield I think a [__]
bullet you know like bring it let's go
Jordan Peterson said literally every
time social justice Warriors come after
him his patreon
he gained two million subscribers when
CNN went after him yeah they who was it
I think it might have been Brett
Weinstein was saying they looked into it
and they said that promotion would
probably cost around 200 million dollars
for all the pro CNN trying to cancel
Rogue 200 million dollars
because for the most part people aren't
idiots they go let me see what's going
oh this is dope and they subscribe yeah
so that promotion yeah keep it up but
those people are might are the enemy in
general they're bad people yes they're
just bad people so but they're doing us
a favor right now all right dude two
people in the crowd the other night
dressed to the nines like a full
three-piece suit and a beautiful evening
dress and I'm like what what are the
what's going on tonight celebrating
they're like oh our plans fell through I
go what were you gonna do they're like
uh Jordan Peterson was supposed to be in
town but he canceled his concert so we
can't sit there like oh what other
misogynist can we see for like twelve
dollars who else is around you pop up
yeah that's a good thing I think I
delivered that night too I gave him
exactly I'll try my best man you're
doing you're doing you're a breath of
fresh air you're doing exciting hey
Brent from New York's an okay guy Brent
from New York is a rock and roll Kid
yeah all right hit us with some current
events sure the breaking news current
events a Canadian comedian is is under
Fire right now hi I'm like oh look at
this you got canceled yeah
George's got this one this is the
article I found a Thai drug dealer had
plastic surgery to look Korean to escape
the police it doesn't look much
different oh and that's right all right
he definitely looks like he lost weight
for sure his hair is different but it
looks like he got proactive he's the
acne and that's it he's got a different
jawline yeah I saw this picture too um
that's his actual face now oh it's his
face now yeah okay I guess his neighbors
Korean so his neighbor said that uh I
don't think that's the right guy because
our next door neighbors when he was
hiding out he's a handsome Korean Yeah
so basically this guy looks uh for
everybody uh he looks uh yeah he was
very was he very Thai and then he tried
to look Korean he's a Thai drug lord
yeah drug lord yeah a lot of MDA to
Bangkok interesting what kind of surgery
I wonder did he get like eyes
eyes do you really wonder chin well you
know how they do that with do you know
what they do how they make your chin
different yeah they shave it filler no
they shave it sometimes but a lot of
times they can just do it with filler no
no not that they get a shave that you're
not a plastic surgeon yeah that ain't
filler buddy his Skin's a lot better
yeah they had to take his is smaller
wait so look at how his you're right
like wait
is he wearing different shoes he's got a
cupid bow now look at that upper lip
that's bow so that's a nice feeling
about this though and look where his
mouth is there and where his mouth is
now how do they do that no it's because
the pictures are it's just a different
height oh I was like huh yeah you see
what the wonderful look his ears are at
150 on the left
I'm saying and then his hair is
different huh yeah different guy this is
a lefty has my haircut on the radius
Brian yeah
he does his mouth is higher somehow he
got taller
yeah he's got a nice I don't like those
lines in the side of his head on the
left he's still got busted oh this one
right here
I'm gonna change my hair and my chin it
was like when Sammy the bull is like
yeah man once I snitch and left I have
to get you know face surgery so they
didn't tell who I was
you look exactly the same Sam you're not
fooling anybody yeah and he's in jail
because of this right now this guy yeah
he's a drug lord should have
transitioned into a woman got off scrap
free right there you go you know what
they do you know what they do to uh drug
dealers in Thailand is I don't a lot of
times one of the punishments is they
make you just kneel on concrete got a
kneel on concrete and sit there and
contemplate for how long
um Years glad you asked sir hours a day
uh your knees on on concrete that that
will start to hurt you can't move either
you got to stay very still and you got
to just think about what you did not
terrible it's actually terrible really
oh yeah it's a terrible punishment to
have to put all your weight on your
inches yeah oh you're naked you
basically well about what they're doing
in uh El Salvador or maybe it's
Nicaragua where they're lining them all
up dude they arrested
something like hundreds right no no no
thousands like literally yeah like I
think it's is it 30 000 or something or
60 000 have been detained they just went
and found all the drug dealers oh drug
dealers yeah because they had like I
mean no no gangsters gangsters covered
in tattoos on their face bodies they're
like you come with us please get in jail
they built a facilities biggest jail in
America it can house 40 000 people and
they literally it's crazy we should do a
show this yeah
then
64 000. oh whoa still looking for 30
000. think about how bad think about how
bad their gang problem is look at them
all nuts to butts yep that's what they
do that'd be fun that must smell really
you put your back on your buddy's
[__] dude that's gotta suck
but that's all they do is read 30 000
put them in like sardines large
the country's murder rate fell 7.8
percent per 100 000 people
last year far more than 50 per 100 000
wow wow wow felt like a [__]
yeah so it's working so of course it's
working his popularity rating that that
president has skyrocketed
it's just like you know obviously
because they can take walks now with
their kids God was like I can walk
around with my kids now I was never
allowed to do that
well good for them yep hell yeah cool
next one so Michael B Jordan when he was
on the red carpet for Creed Three uh a
girl that he went to high school with
was doing the red carpet she made fun of
him calm corny yeah she said on a
podcast she thought he forgot so she's
interviewing for creed and he got she
goes hey how you doing it's pretty good
she was with a long time since high
schools it has been a long time is on
the corny kid though right and you see
and she's actually a dime piece but she
he goes on the corner kid right you can
see she's like oh no that yeah and he's
like no that's what you say about me you
can tell he's not having it and he's
been on his Spike tour ever since yeah
oh yeah he's doing what you did yeah let
me see this good for him he's not you
know we know each other we go way back
all the way to Chad science and Newark
okay right
I didn't say that misquoted for sure
you did not hear me say cry I said we
used to make fun of the name but yeah he
is obviously killing things out here
and there's a podcast clip that it's her
also called corny using his poster for
click she's posing with how weird is
that so that was the corny kid the corny
kid what she said that in in high school
she said that when she was in high
school and she said she did like I said
oh I used to call him the corny it's a
weird thing to call somebody yeah it
definitely is you know what I mean like
there are other insults but like you're
like you're corny dude I I don't know
corny I don't know what I would do I
would go I'd go what's corn I I might be
like oh God me because that's a really
good insult no but for a comic hey bro
on this podcast you were Pony
[__] foreign
[__] but there are a lot when a
white guy says corny it's not really a
put down but I think coming out of a
black voice corny I'm sorry bigger sting
you're about to get cancer because oh
that's a bad ticket sales are going up
damn foiled again yeah corny is horny is
worse in Black Culture than white yeah I
would assume yeah I agree I guess I
agree with bread on this it's such a way
you're corner like you know how I know
you're getting your corny call me corny
and that just means I probably yeah
maybe I am a little corny sometimes and
by the way I am a little corny sometimes
you're pretty corny you know what I mean
Courtney's a weird word Courtney's a
weird word
dumb uh like
laughed so hard one time I said he said
well I I said to this person I go you're
a dum-dum you know and you're so basic
so then one time he this woman kept
talking in a show and he goes no no no
no no no no
you're dumb
dumb dumb it was great so it was like
that was a great word that we used to it
caught someone dumb dumb and then I
remember one time the guy this guy was
this huge guy a giant man he had not
been missing any meals but he was tough
and I pulled in and I was standing there
and he like so my car was here and his
car was he was facing his car was here
but he was in the opposite direction yes
so he I still have to stop because he
thought I was going to run into him and
he's he's already swearing at me as I'm
coming and then and I'm there and he
goes you got a [__] problem man you
got a [__] problem what the [__] do
you think and I just looked and I went
you're fat is he fat he goes yeah
it's like such a lame comeback shut up
yep but uh and I would never ever say
that but he was such a dick but corny
[__] corny
that would stop me in my tracks if I was
doing something what how's it comic I'd
be like oh yeah oh okay you're right
yeah you're right I'll stop
corny
anyway Justice it's not a bad insult
though no it's fine if she's going on
podcasts on this she's like what's up
good to see you old school and he's like
I'm the corny kid though why do you call
me corny by the way was I corny and I'd
be like I like the way he did yeah no no
corny kid right you dumb [__]
well he he's already won though oh yeah
all right guys well it's good he checked
her especially like an a-lister here's a
shout out to Michael B Jordan I said
toron uh tactical uh Taryn Butler Terran
tactical I said who's the who's the most
because I saw that who's the guy who's
the what's Taryn tactical oh I'm sorry
The Punisher uh guy trains there trains
John Wick he trained uh Keanu Reese John
Wick he trained um John John Bernthal
for I mean every every movie star you
can imagine he trains okay he's like he
was one of the best competition Shooters
in the world for like a long long time
all right give us the story for God's
sakes so um
uh what was I talking about Michael B
Jordan
yeah so so I'm watching that that
Formula One driver what's his name out
Hamilton uh yeah uh Lewis Hamilton and
he had never done it before and he was
[__] amazing because what you're
doing an obstacle course you're shooting
real guns you're like and you're hitting
him he's hitting every Target like just
dude yeah because his eye His Eye Is So
Good his reaction yeah I was like [__]
he looked like he'd been doing it
forever I said is there anybody better
than that and he goes Michael B Jordan
Michael B Jordan was the best first time
shooter I've ever seen that's saying a
lot when you've been in the space so he
he's got something going on respect yeah
something going on you're talking about
the A-list movie star I mean he could
really do so no no no no I'm talking
about being able to shoot like that
that's really something there he's got
something guy worth a hundred mil yeah
I'm talking about hitting like every
Target never done it yeah if you want to
see it in competition make no money he
definitely but I'm still still that that
says more about his hand eye
coordination his reaction time
everything so he's it's the real deal
he's the real deal good actor and he
wants to fight
story oh
that was a long time ago yeah I remember
yeah
um let's just do this one real quick so
the department you the U.S department of
energy I guess someone in their team
leaked information that yeah it could
most likely be a lab leak for covet 19.
so the FBI what a surprise but then but
I thought so I thought we were all bad
people so I'm racist yeah racist oh my
God low confidence they said low
confidence of course the White House
putting that out there yeah of course I
heard this on the radio on the way down
here and Oh weird I thought we were all
conspiracy I thought we were racist
conspiracies why because the strain of
that virus had wasn't found on any of
the bats in that area
um and they were doing gain of function
research even though fashion said they
weren't have you seen the news on the
mass that they don't work at all I've
even seen in putting that up that mass
don't work in any capacity this is crazy
this is so weird two years it was eyes
only it was a Saudi Arabian summer yeah
two years two years
let's shut down the whole world isn't
that crazy keep kids uh I thought we
were all bad people and conspiracy and I
thought we'd take care of each other so
wear a mask and get your vaccine oh yeah
it didn't come from a lab you're racist
and shut down all businesses I know you
spend your whole life building a
business but that all goes away but
we'll be fine because we we have a job
we're in news we're in politics we're in
Academia isn't it crazy we we we're
we're in think tanks we have our jobs
but how's this going for them and then
you know Littlefoot in uh Chicago she's
out yeah she's just by 85 percent
because she blamed on racism
okay not on
not on so bad it's a war zone it has
nothing to do with you doing your job
100 black people were killed in one
weekend it's because her gender and
racism I see yes okay that's why she got
tired yeah wouldn't this just be a
reason to go to war with China
wait a minute hold on dude that's a huge
jump but I'm I'm where did you go oh
[__] man you're right right now do you
see Ukraine's con saying that America is
going to send their sons and daughters
to war if Ukraine loses he said America
told him that we're willing to send our
daughters and sons to war for Ukraine
who said that the silence well well um
Biden in Europe has stood behind Ukraine
because they want to bleed Russia dry
that's a it's going to be another hey
you know what with the amount of hate
Russia gets you're a tennis guy right
you've been watching tennis they always
put the flag for the name right if
you're a Russian player you just get a
little white square I know so petty and
stupid that with the amount people hate
Russia I love Russia more I'm literally
seeing a Russian right now that I love I
like the Russian people I don't want the
Russian people to be [__] killed the
rest of people don't want these things I
don't want Russian oligarchs like hey
what are you doing I know dude they take
our [__] yards I had a good thing
going too
that like all those young men getting
thrown to [__] the meat Rider Yeah
the more the world hates Russia the more
I like Russia that's how I feel about
you yes
I must be your favorite person yeah yeah
me and Justin Trudeau are your two
favorite cuts are you guys doing the
show Brian's just long gone what else
you got Jen uh how many more you want
one more all right this one I thought
was interesting because uh remember Kobe
Bryant's ah you know there was like
pictures of him like after him
yeah yeah so his wife uh his widow sorry
I didn't know this I actually didn't
hold on yeah hold on it's it's 2019. the
first people died yeah Brian just found
out that when I see that stuff they
started spreading it around when I see
that I don't read it because it makes me
sad it's so sad but yeah she will
definitely didn't look for the picture
you were watching Canadian Parliament
instead so do you mean the caustic
pictures and sentences of the bodies yes
but the bodies were like charred and
strong heads why would you want to see
you're talking about you know uh Kobe
Bryant who's a you know and his daughter
and there's other people some other
white people on the plane
so anyways so she'd filed a lawsuit
against whoa whoa hey dude oh dear
Griffin's joke and it's on special he
goes Kobe Bryant was so loved you forget
seven white people
that's a great joke yeah a reference to
his job so she sued the LA county and
she won over around 30 million dollars
off of that losses which she should
because that's so [__] up that woman
to the right
I think
yeah that's terrible where were you when
you heard the news that's one of those 9
11 moments right yeah I was on a plane
flying back from Philadelphia it's my
birthday his hometown yeah his hometown
and I remember Derek Poston was like
holy [__] Kobe died and he started
crying yeah I was like you're from
Memphis what are you doing I was at a
Good Life Fitness in Winnipeg
um yeah it was tragic man and then
remember he died not far from here so
the traffic because I from the airport
the traffic was nuts because everyone
was rushing but for whatever [__]
reason everyone was rushed into the
crime scene so the traffic was nuts all
your city buses said R.A R.I.P Kobe for
weeks man it was really nice to see
everyone how many a thousand basketballs
left in front of the Staples Center yeah
yeah it was incredible it was horrible
what was that Montana Hunter thing oh so
remember that's not in on Kobe's death
huh yeah but this is like you want one
more
um because it just came out so hold on
remember the girl that accidentally or
not yeah she accidentally shot skinned a
husky yeah a husky I think it is a wolf
no no she's not something
but I'm like bringing this back up
because remember she had it skinned she
had yeah she has problems and you can't
tell after you killed it that it's not a
husky look at this dog it's a husky yeah
but you know you get excited yeah she
thought it was a wolf yeah her arcade
after you get it back and you're gonna
skin it oh yeah you should know it's a
husky yeah that's close that's closer
than the Korean I'm sure and though to
me that's closer I don't want to just
say to people listening Brett is
pointing to a husky and a [__] wolf
it's closer it's a closer
Korean and I I for one I think right
this this podcast the racist meter
red hot and it stayed red hot the whole
time so hey sold out here
I'm quietly outraged I gotta take off
hey guys uh first week of April Arizona
House of Comedy yes uh come on now
Bronson's house you're with me and Brea
this Friday yeah if you want to see uh
Brett get more canceled uh come see us
in Brea two shows just Friday we have to
cancel Saturday because Saturday we had
a big fighting game it's Jon Jones
returned and Beau Nichols that Saturday
live 7 P.M on thick boy YouTube you got
jelly roll you got Will Compton from
busting with the Bros
on Friday very cool yep
um and then you have Rampage Jackson
That's Saturday 7 P.M live for UFC 285
so Brea is this Friday with Brett and me
then Oklahoma City's next week March 9th
through 11th breakdown Comedy Club
Tacoma Washington March 23rd through the
25th get Joe tickets
f-a-t-k-z.com so kids I'm gonna be at
Zanies Saturday's already sold out
Friday is getting very close get your
tickets Zanies I'll be there Thursday
March 2nd to Saturday March 4th
um and Friday when I'm in Nashville I'm
going to be doing a crowd cast I'm going
to be doing I'm going to be doing
something with Stephen Cutler who is a
flow expert we're going to do a q a and
he talks about Peak Performance aging
he's got this book called our country
where he at 53. no no listen no no at 53
he literally did
um he wrote this book about doing like
Park skiing which is really dangerous
and how you get into flow but we're
going to do this whole thing on it so
that's a crowd cat wow 12 30 Pacific
time to yourself Tune In Tune in Friday
and then Sony Hall March 11th one show
only doors open at 7 30. come get some
show starts at 8 30. Sony Hall New York
New York then Levity Live March 16th to
the 18th all right kids love you Brett
you're the best thank you Brett from New
York
Brentford New York love you guys